بعد ثلاث سنوات من الحادث وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق مايك بومبيو يكشف كواليس
عمليه اغتيال قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني
قاسم سليماني القصه بدات حينما كتب بومبيو
رساله الى سليمانيه هدده فيها بان امريكا
ستحاسبه وستاسبه ايران على هجماتها ضد
المصالح الامريكيه في العراق لكن الاخيره
لم يرد
سنحاسبك وسنحاسب ايران على هجماتها ضد
المصالح الامريكيه في العراق بعد ذلك
بسنتين وفي منزل ترامب في فلوريدا الى
جانب وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان المشتركه
تم تقديم توصيه التاليه
سيدي الرئيس لدينا توصيه لك الهدف هو
الجنرال قاسم سليماني سيدي الرئيس سليماني
مسافر من بيروت الى دمشق ثم بغداد ويطيروا
عبر رحلات تجاريه ونعرف طريقه رحلته انه
يتامر لقتل المزيد من الامريكيين لدينا
الادوات الضروريه لوقف قيادته لهذه الجهود
الاجراميه لقد اسقطوا مسيرتين امريكيتين
اطلقوا صواريخ بالستيه العالم مملكه
العربيه السعوديه والان قتلوا امريكيا حان
الوقت لوقف حكمه الاجرامي هذا هدف عسكري
المشروع ترامب على الخطه المقترحه وبعد
موافقته جرى تحديد الثالث من يناير 2020
موعدا للعمليه وصل سليمان الى مطار بغداد
الدولي حيث استقبله القيادي في ميليشيا
الحشد الشعبي ابو مهدي المهندس مع انطلاق
موكب سليمان والمهندس كانت مسيره
كيه من طراز ام كيو 9 ريفر تتقفى كل
حركاته معه
مغادره سياره سليمانيه المطار سقطت عليهما
صواريخها الفاير بومبيو كتب ان العمليه في
مجملها استغرقت خمس دقائق فقط دون قلق من
وقوع اصابات جانبيه بين المدنيين لان كل
الخطط تمت بعنايه
قاسم اسامه بلال البوجداني العربيه